i dated an older guy last year and we
went on a road trip every song on his
playlist was like wild it was like hey
little girl is your daddy home
did he go and leave you all alone i was
like oh god
i used to love that song
that shit does not hit the same way but
the good thing about dating older guys
is that every now and then you get to
listen to r kelly by accident
because they didn't hear about it
okay yahoo news or whatever
didn't cover that story oh wow you're
gonna try to be woke with me newark you
sure
you're gonna try to tell me when the r
kelly ignition remix comes on
and it's not your fault that that isn't
a gift from god
i'm not an asshole i'm not just gonna
enjoy the song i'm obviously going to
educate him you know i'm going to be
like baby you need to turn this song off
you need a turn
you need to turn this song off
immediately this man is disgusted this
man
this man was a sexual predator
what he did was wrong
he objectified women
there's a documentary i need you to
watch immediately
there's a gail king interview i need you
to turn on
and you need to turn this song off in
three minutes